well this is I think possibly the best
board game ever which is quite a bold
claim many people talk about this as
just the perfect game it involves
strategy and a little bit of luck as
well because of the role of the dice um
it's a actually a game which it people
play together there's talking all the
time there's trading going on uh
sometimes games suffer because the
person playing that particular turn is
the only person really being involved in
the other Sitting Waiting for the this
one involves everyone this is called the
settlers of Katan it was created by a
German dentist who also loved board
games and it won the Spiel desas which
is kind of Nobel Prize of um gaming in
Germany it's the sort of game which gets
a mathematician immediately excited
because just look at the layout of this
board it's um hexagons not squares and
hexagons are just such a beautiful shape
and the tessellation of the plane using
hexagon so as soon as I saw this game I
I was getting very excited but you'll
see there also numbers on here so let me
tell you a little bit about how you play
the game so you'll see there are
different sorts of squares there's
Woodland here and Woodland will generate
a different resource of logs the mine
hexagons give you ore the pasture
hexagons allow you to graze sheep the
fields then we can grow some wheat
and then in the Hills you can dig out
stuff to make bricks and each of these
will allow you to build different things
now how do you get these well if you own
a property and it's on say the corner of
these hexagons we're going to see which
of these is going to generate some
resources in this turn and I'm going to
throw some dice and I've got 10 so those
areas of land which have the number 10
on them will be
generating uh in this case 10 is
generating a sheep so this will generate
a sheep for anybody who's got a property
on the the corner of this land but
unfortunately I I've not generated
anything because I wanted a five four
and 11 so if I'd been here I would have
got some sheep resources interestingly
what's the chance of getting for example
if I'm here of getting a 12
unfortunately there's only one way to
get a 12 with two dice which is a six
and a six and this is what this little
dot at the bottom here is telling me
that this is actually quite a hard thing
to generate resources from so is it a
good idea to put your property here
because there's only one chance well
look at six for example this has got
five dots underneath it why because well
to get a six how many different ways can
I get a six there are five because I can
get a five and a one or a four and a two
two or three and a three two and a four
or a one and a five so there are five
different ways to get a six four
different ways to get a a five so these
little dots actually help you to do the
probability in this game because um
let's see you know the if I put a
property here I've got 1 + 5 6 Plus
another four that's 10 kind of different
ways the role of the dice can generate
things for me here um let's choose
somewhere else just calculate uh let's
let let's go here that was 10 so here we
got 3 + 2 + 4 that's only nine so this
is a less strategic place to put your
property because only nine out of the 36
different things are going to generate
resources so this is what you need to do
when you're playing Katan so a little
bit of mathematical strategy here will
help you to choose which Corners to go
on because you want to add up those dots
cuz that's telling you um the
probability you're going to add up those
probabilities that you're going to
generate some resources if you put your
property there this is why a little bit
of mathematics can help you to play this
game there must be more to it than just
who can crunch the numbers the best
though to win this game or well there's
actually a lot of psychology involved
because once you've got resources you
might have found you just generated a
lot of sheep and what are you going to
do with all these sheep and you need to
start trading so that's actually why
this game is so beautiful but it
involves a lot of conversations and I'll
give I've got loads of sheet but I want
some some some logs will you trade me
and there's a little and that's not
determined by the game that's determined
by how much you need something and how
much you can see your opponent needs
things oh do you have any clay you trade
a rock for a clay but let me talk about
another mathematical aspect of the game
which I think is rather beautiful it's
not about strategy whilst playing the
game but it's about how you set the game
up because if you notice this is a lot
of hexagons placed down on the board now
i' place it down in a particular way we
got the mines uh placed here there are
three mines here but the beauty of this
game is each time you set it up you can
lay the hexagons down in a new way each
time cuz these are like these are
modular they are so you know we could
have set this up such that uh this was
uh swapped over and so actually perhaps
there's a lot of Woodland you know we
could have a a whole great big Forest
here so the numbers actually must stay
the same although they can actually
rotate so I was intrigued about you know
well how many different games are in
this box you know Monopoly you only get
one board there any one game but there
are so many games inside this box
because of the permutations you can do
so um I thought it might be fun with
your number file audience just to
calculate how many different boards
there there can be the hexagons can go
can they go anywhere is there any rules
or restrictions on no there are none at
all so it sounds like it would be quite
easy then it is quite easy but there's a
little bit of subtlety here because
obviously so you'd say okay how many
squares are there well hexagons yeah how
many oh my gosh yes yeah there's like
how many hex how many hexagons are there
okay three
seven what's that 12 16 is that 19 19
and these are called hex numbers so hex
numbers go 1 7 19 and it's the number of
hexagons you need you know we made there
are expansion
of Katan this is the basic version
little challenge for number file uh
viewers uh what's the formula for you
know like the a Katan board with n
layers there's a way you can generate
these hex
numbers the hex number for this board is
19 there are actually 19 factorial
different ways can lay the hexans down
so you know I can let's we can start in
the middle there are 19 hexagons I can
put the first one down there then we we
go around in a circle and then do this
circle so at first side it looks like
there are 19 factorial different games
you can play in the settlers of Katan uh
but you have to remember some of these
hexagons are actually the same because
I've got three different hexagons which
are mines so actually I could have put
these down like this and the board
hasn't really changed it means that
these three mines can be permuted around
and I don't really get a new game so I
need to divide that 19 Factor by three
factorial for the mines now the other
resources there are I think four um oh
no let's see look there are only three
of the hills so there another divide by
three factorial the other ones are all
four so there are three of those so I
need divide by three factorial 3
factorial four factorial four factorial
four factorial uh and that will give me
uh the total number of so let's just add
that up make sure that uh 4 + 4 + 4 12
plus plus 3 15 + 3 18 and you get put
there in 19 and that's because there's
actually a little desert if you generate
the number seven you'll see that seven
isn't anywhere here it's the most common
throw of the dice and so that has a
different function in the game um so
that's given us our 19 hexagons 19
factorial divided by 3 factorial squar
divided by four factorial cubed it's the
total number of ways I can lay these
hexagons down what number does that give
us it gives us uh a very large number
and I think I remember when I calculated
it if we played a different game each
night ever since the dinosaurs were
around we'd still be playing on
different boards so so that's quite a
lot of in fact let's let's look it up
cuz I did actually calculate in my new
book about
games
um here we go my little hexagons um
there are actually 244 billion 432 milon
188,000 different boards in that way
actually there is a little few more
subtleties to this um which you have to
take into account so um the way these
numbers can be laid on the board
actually it's a fixed way but they can
be rotated in six different ways so
actually you that you have to multiply
up by another six um and then there's
another subtly which I haven't talked
about which are little ports that you
can land in and they do different things
in the game which also determine another
few factors more of the way that you can
play this game so there are a lot of
games contained in this one single box
is Katana game where people debate
strategy or yeah there's a lot of debate
of strategy about where to place um your
properties as you're settling Katan um
and so that's important to look at these
numbers because you want to go places
where you're more likely to be
generating resources because of where
you've placed your uh properties um
there's also Al uh another part of the
game which is laying roads so you're
interested in in making the longest road
and that wins you things in the game and
so again there's an interesting strategy
about um how am I actually going to lay
roads through this tessellation of
hexagons um what's the longest road
that's possible um in the settlers of
Katan that's another nice little
mathematical challenge Professor you're
a
mathematician and you like playing games
do you often play games with other
mathematicians uh yes because very often
people who are not mathematicians get
wise to the fact that this guy seems to
have some tricks up his sleeve and I
often find my children stop playing
games where I have a kind of an
advantage because of my mathematical uh
goggles but uh yeah there's I mean a lot
of mathematicians love playing games but
I think you'll find that many
mathematicians do not like a game which
involves any element of chance they like
it to be pure strategy so games like
chess or the the game of Go Chinese game
of Go intriguingly though chess
originally came from India and it
actually involved dice so the early
versions of Chess you would throw a dice
in order to determine which piece you
were allowed to move and then the use of
dice and gambling was banned in India
and people had to take these dice away
and then they thought but actually we
can just play this is a pure strategy
game so I think people uh might be
surprised to learn one of the things I
learned when writing this book about
games is that um actually dice were part
of Chess originally have you ever played
a game of chess using that rule that'd
be amazing yeah I think it's um a bit
rubbish actually because you know you're
really wanting to move your knight and
the the role of the dice is uh forcing
you to move the rook and um there's
another interesting thing I discovered
about Chess um which is it wasn't a
two-player game originally but four
player game and as you can see that um
in the game that survived because your
army consists of two knights two Bishops
two Rooks and the point is that you
actually captured one of the other
players armies and it became part of
your your army and that's why you see
these doubling up of pieces in the game
do you know what I would love to know
cuz I'm not good at chesra I I I know
the rules but I'm not if I played
against Magnus Carlson a game of chess
where I could move any piece and he
could only move pieces determined by
dice who would win the game I think it's
a really interesting experiment yeah we
should set that up and just see you know
how much of a handicap is it to be
forced to play certain pieces in the
game I think for me as well chess
suffers a little bit because anyone who
knows their openings um actually has
such a big Advantage so um they can get
to a place in the game if you don't know
your openings you're already weak after
11 moves which is why sometimes I think
if you're playing somebody who's really
good at chess it's probably good to stop
in mid game and start from both armies
being in a strong position because of a
Sicilian Defense for example if you're a
fan of games check out today's episode
sponsor Jane Street they love games so
much in fact they've even invented one
more about that in a sec Jane Street's a
quantitative trading firm with officers
all around the world you see there
now obviously they're passionate about
solving high stakes complex problems
it's part of their business they're
experts at machine learning mathematics
statistics all that kind of stuff and
that problem solving passion extends to
puzzles and games the team at Jan Street
often spend free time playing each other
at chess and go and yes even Katan and
they created this card game called figgy
to simulate elements of markets and
trading it looks pretty cool something
you might be into you can play it online
at figgy
do.com so why don't you go and have a
look at that and while you're there
check out Jane Street as a place where
you might like to work as you can see
they've got all sorts of jobs
internships training programs available
there's always new stuff coming up on
the site check it out janest street.com
or see the links in the video
description I've got the link to Jan
Street and figgy down
there
check out more videos with Marcus dorto
you know he's really into games in fact
he's got a new book out at the moment
called Around the World in 80 games I'm
also going to link to that in the video
description interested as a sculptor in
yeah well what about taking this Atomic
shape the tetrahedron and and seeing
what you can build this was
mathematicians hope that okay there's
some the weird logical Gillian sentences
which who really cares about